at least 25 People have been killed in a
Blast in the Russian held Ukrainian City
ofet Russian officials controlling The
Area claim The shells that Hit A busy
Market Sunday were fired by the
Ukrainian Military Ke has not commented
on the incident while Russia's Foreign
ministry has denounced  The Strike City
was First Seed by Russian Back Forces in
2014 and the Area has
a cotton and then I look straight at the road, I
see how the smoke T broke through the
hot water pipe and there was this smoke of steam, I’m already
approaching
right on the spot No
note, she’s
constantly every day now
cumin Probably  I don’t know, some woman, someone
else’s phone from my wife, I was at work, they all
said no, that’s all, she
was selling in the store’s market, and
apparently she was
passing by. Here, she probably passed by, or most likely passed by,
because half of her body was lying under the table.  I
already pulled everything out myself, I
arrived still warm, but it’s
no longer
N